un village de Gaspésie typique la mer
une vieille église le chantier naval des
pêcheurs un peu partout
le transport du bois
ici on élément de décor unique qui
t'arrange avec leur est le monument à la
jeune soldat de Karine Blais
magnifique petite fille charmante
il était toujours de bonne humeur je
vois souvent des tours
c'était une enfant que tout le monde à
avoir la caporal Karine Blais est morte
à 21 ans en Afghanistan moins de 2
semaines après son arrivée sur place
déterminée aller sauver
le petit peuple qu'elle a pas de colle à
l'époque des verriers
secondaire 3 carte de tous les gens
[Musique]
c'est vraiment la photo si elle que
toutes les étapes
parce que je voulais pause je vais très
très très fort
puis moi je me suis entraîné
je veux pas laisser mes comptes je veux
du Royal 22e Régiment et est au volant
d'un véhicule blindé de reconnaissance
sur une route de la région de Kandar le
13 avril 2009 en fin d'après-midi et la
rouler sur une de ses bombe artisanale
que les talibans répandait un peu
partout elle est morte sur le coup 4
autres soldats ont été blessé
Karine Blais est l'une des deux seules
femme parmi le groupe des 158 soldats
canadiens morts en Afghanistan entre
2002 et 2014 chante jour 1 sa présence
autour de moi et tout le temps arrive de
quoi car il me donner un coup de main
pour
vivre
excusez-moi
fiche pas mal ce gamin il a
fait 3 mission à la distance entre 2008
et 2011 dans les mêmes que Karine Blais
il connaît bien sa mère José Simard à
titre de représentante des parents de
soldats tués José Simard est allée en
Afghanistan après la mort de sa fille
vraiment dans quel compte est-ce que tu
croyais vraiment
je t'en venu avec un goût amer parce que
je trouvais que ça valait pas vraiment
la peine
jeux avec des soldats qui me répond pas
je venais avec des gens qui était
dévasté par la guêpe
après la tragédie Josie Simard se lancer
dans la restauration pour tenter de
tromper sa peine mais l'esprit de Karine
demeure bien présent dans sa cuisine
j'ai acheté du travail
après le frigo est tout le temps avec
lui dans le village de Karine Blais les
gens qui l'ont connu sont bouleversés
par la tournure récente des événements
en Afghanistan
bac pour enfants
pour
détruire des familles des trucs du monde
si quand même par rapport avec
[Musique]
le religion le mode de vie et personne
qui est allé le voir
au moins essayé
à l'aide que le Canada à apporter à la
population construction d'école pour les
filles développement de l'agriculture de
l'électricité Monsieur Madame tout le
monde
c'est pas toi qui va faire je t'aimais
que Jojo
est
[Musique]
vraiment beaucoup
je n'arrivais pas à Sion d'oublier les
sacrifices de Karine
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elle croit encore
à la mission c'est ce que je me manques